this is a big question right you know
why did we go to afghanistan what was
the mission well the mission was to stop
them from planning which was a stupid
idea they planned it in hamburg germany
you can plan it anywhere you don't need
to be in afghanistan and then they'd
show the film on the news of the
terrorists on the monkey bars
that's absolutely right
and americans spent all the money in the
troops but we got we got fixed in that
that rental vision that mindset that bin
laden was in afghanistan
we've got to go there and we've got to
stay there until we can say it will
never happen again which of course means
we'll be there forever right and your
book really is sort of the modern
pentagon papers i mean it is astounding
and sad
how similar this
played out to vietnam
it's like we just did this [ __ ] and then
we did it again we forget
one generation just completely forget
which don't get me
we should teach history in school maybe
maybe that would help but
what your new pentacon papers book
really has the same theme which is that
they lied to us they presented a rosy
picture in public for all these years
and behind the scenes they knew it was
unwinnable and they just weren't telling
us liars and this went from the
beginning really uh there are memos we
obtained from donald rumsfeld who was
bush's defense secretary
and in public people are asking him is
this going to be another vietnam or are
we going to get stuck in a quagmire and
rumso would make fun of journalists who
would ask this then in private just six
months in the war he sends a memo to his
his military chief saying
if we don't get a plan to stabilize
afghanistan our troops are going to get
stuck there forever
and he ends the memo with one word it
says help exclamation point right and
you see this go on year after year after
year in public they say things are
getting better we're making progress
we're turning the corner and yet in
private in diplomatic cables memos
conferences internally they're saying
things are a mess and they know that
slowly this war is slipping from their
grasp and it's gradually becoming
unwinnable the one that mystifies me
though is obama
obama ran and i loved it when he said
i'm not against all wars i'm against
dumb wars i was like that's my guy you
know because i feel the same way can't
be against all wars there's evil in the
world sometimes you got to be a badass
and america has more than not
stepped up
but
but this was a dumb war
and he kind of doubled down on it i mean
how could a guy that bright think you
could do what we were trying to do surge
take over the country flood it with
money and that would change things
around when really it was just doing the
opposite what's your take on that well
obama you have to remember when he ran
for office the first time he was saying
iraq was the dumb war right and we're
going to get out of iraq no question and
he did eventually pull troops out of
iraq but he said afghanistan and
afghanistan well no when he first ran he
said afghanistan was the just war this
was the just cause that americans this
was a war of self-defense originally
because of september 11th but that war
was already over for many years by the
time he got there i mean if it was a
just war
certainly after he got bin laden
what was left to do i mean it morphed
into nation building it morphed into
this ridiculous idea as in vietnam that
we could change hearts and minds when by
the things we were doing there you only
lose hearts and minds well and that's
right and each president
said both bush obama and trump all
promise the american people in public
we're not nation-building in afghanistan
we're not doing it even though at that
very moment that's exactly what we were
doing the united states spent more than
100 billion dollars nation building in
afghanistan that's more than we spent in
europe on the marshall plan after world
war ii and now it's all gone up in smoke
you